You know I've always
been suspicious of friends.
What starts over a shared
interest in paintball
comes to a screeching halt
four years later when I have
to memorize your wife's name.
Nice try
Gary why don't you go home
to blonde hair and blue shoes.
Friends are dangerous
and no one knows
that more than America's number
one friend Donald Trump.
He went to the G7
summit this weekend
which, in case you don't know,
is where the U.S. meets
with our top allies
to discuss the world economy
and diplomatic priorities.
So you know what Trump did.
Ask Info Wars: he body slammed
it and that's not hyperbole.
This is actual footage of Trump
walking into the summit.
Here he is, walking in... there
it is and SLAM.
SLAM. Take that.
That'll teach you to be
ideologically aligned with us
on almost every
geopolitical issue.
Of course the leftist media
sees some sort of problem
with this. That Trump
is alienating all his allies
and acting like
a petulant child.
But does this look
like a petulant child?
This is obviously
a power stance.
Everyone knows the real way
to be in charge
is to make your body resemble
a pouty mini refrigerator.
But get used to it world.
For everyone wondering
what the Trump foreign policy
doctrine is.
History got an answer.
Three words.
Senior White House
official quoted today
the Trump doctrine
is "We're America, bitch."
We're America...
Bitch. What a doctrine.
Now I know there's
a word in there
that liberals
will find offensive.
America. Those bitches
need to chill.
This is what "we're America
bitch"
looks like. You show up
whatever the hell you want to.
Trump left late
for the summit on Friday.
Landing an hour behind schedule.
When asked why he was late,
one White House official
told NBC News quote
"He is the president."
He, again, showed up late
this time 20 minutes
late for a breakfast discussion
on gender equality.
They should be happy. The
meeting was on gender equality.
So Trump graciously
only participated
in 77 percent of it.
He didn't stop there.
Trump took his doctorine
to America's upstairs
neighbor Canada.
Canada drives me crazy.
It's like somebody
took Bernie Sanders
and stretched him
into an entire country.
And, it's
led by Prime Minister "swimming
pool eyes" Justin Trudeau
who set himself and his country
up as America's
enemy number one.
If you were Canada's Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau
just heating up. -Canada
maybe the closest U.S. ally
and promised retaliatory
trade moves in response
to steep new tariffs announced
by the Trump administration.
Trump firing back
calling Trudeau weak.
His advisers are saying
Canada's Justin Trudeau
stabbed the president
in the back.
Oh you can't stab
Trump in the back.
He's got eyes back there.
He sees everything.
Listen to Trudeau's
vicious vulgar threats.
Canadians, we're polite
we're reasonable
but we also will
not be pushed around.
Oh, filthy! Filthy.
I am sorry that everyone at home
will have to wash
their DVR's out with soap.
Pretty big words from someone
who is taking advantage
of America
by taxing dairy
from us at 270%,
according to Trump's Twitter.
What is Canada
trying to do to us
with this 270% milk tax?
Milk comes in 1%, 2%,
and whole. What kind of
a monster country demands
270% milk?
This shit is dense like
a black hole of lactose.
No.
Bean counting economist
nerds are taking Canada's side
saying that Trump is a bully
and pointing out
that Canada brings in twice
as much dairy from the U.S.
as it exports
and that dairy
is only about point
two percent of the total value
of goods exported to Canada.
But last I checked one fifth
of 1% is still some.
So Trump isn't being a bully.
He's just pushing around
a smaller weaker kid
and literally stealing
his milk money.
Stop picking on us, Canada!
We're America, bitch!
You know what, Trump doesn't
have time for any G7 nerds
because right now
the president is in Singapore
sitting down with Kim Jong Un
negotiating historic peace.
And if they're lucky, North
Korea
will one day become
the type of ally
that we can bodyslam
on the world
stage.